le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
l'île de la Réunion classée patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité pour plus de 40%
de sa superficie regorge de réserves
naturelles unique au monde
parmi les sites les plus populaires il y
a le volcan c'est la star des sites
visiter à la Réunion la route qui mène
jusqu'au volcan offre une grande
diversité de paysages de points de vue
et d'aire de repos très fréquentés mais
cette grande fréquentation entraîne
aussi des dégradations alors comment
protéger ces lieux uniques tout en les
partageant et en gardant leur
authenticité on en parle maintenant dans
lien social
à la Réunion 40% du territoire et 95% de
la forêt domaniale et la propriété du
Conseil Général
c'est une grande fierté pour le
département mais aussi une grande
responsabilité
l'entretien de ces sites demande
beaucoup d'investissements et de moyens
humains pour que les réunionnais et les
touristes profitent au mieux de ces
lieux particuliers le Conseil Général
entreprend des actions pour les
améliorer il réaffirme son attachement à
valoriser les hauts sous tous leurs
aspects économiques sociales culturels
touristiques mais aussi naturel
la préservation des espèces remarquables
de l'île doit se concilier avec
l'appropriation continue de sites par
les Réunionnais
c'est ce double objectif que le Conseil
Général poursuit avec ses partenaires au
profit de la population réunionnaise ce
travail avec les partenaires comme l'ONF
porte ses fruits car le taux de
fréquentation augmente chaque année un
succès qui entraîne des aménagements
qu'il faut penser de manière économique
et écologique on est dans une démarche
de
modernisation et d'offres
à la population réunionnaise de d'offres
agréables d'accueil sur ces sites qui
sont plus de 130 aujourd'hui qui est
géré par les services du département
avec notre partenaire je dirais officiel
que l'Office national des forêts ses
actions
un pour but de préserver le côté naturel
de ces de nos forêts de ces sites
d'accueil de nos sentiers pour que
demain les réunionnais et les touristes
puissent bénéficier de ce de ce panorama
qui est l'ensemble de la forêt de la
reine
suite au classement mondial à l'Unesco
des noces de nos siècles de nos remparts
et du classement de nos forêts en parc
national aujourd'hui le parc national
est un partenaire aussi essentiel dans
l'aménagement de nos forêts dans la
valorisation et dans la préservation de
ces de ces sites et ses airs d'accueil
et c'est important aujourd'hui que les
Réunionnais s'approprient je dirais ces
territoires mais aussi qui le préserve
et qui le valorise eux-mêmes il y a le
côté écotouriste qui est important
l'aménagement décida d'accueil
l'entretien de nos sentiers apportent je
dirais
du travail à notre jeunesse plus de 700
jeunes aujourd'hui travaillent sur
l'entretien et la préservation et la
création de sentiers
et justement
ceci pourront demain être aussi mise en
valeur
économiquement par les gens qui habitent
qui habitent
ces efforts et ses actions sur
l'aménagement des sites des hauts font
plaisir aux visiteurs qu'ils soient
réunionnais ou d'ailleurs ils apprécient
de pouvoir profiter de ces sites
sauvages avec des aménagements adaptés
et confortables pouvant accueillir
parents et enfants
admirer la vue etc je pense qu'au niveau
facilité pour faire pique-nique en
famille etc oui il y en a à peu près
partout c'est disséminé partout je pense
qu'il y a la place pour tout le monde
maintenant effectivement il y a toutes
les facilités nécessaires pour apprécier
un petit pique-nique en famille
côté amélioration je vois pas vraiment
parce que il faudrait pas trop trop
améliorer non plus parce qu'après ça va
des paysagers
cet endroit un peu spécial les points de
vue bon il y en a il y en a pas
énormément par rapport au reliés au
graphique mais je pense qu'ils sont bien
placés de toute façon ils sont passés
dans une logique
dans la logique du paysage mais
effectivement si on aurait si on pouvait
en installer plus ça pourrait être ça
peut être que positif de façon au niveau
des touristes etc dans le cadre de leur
politique environnementale l'ONF et le
Conseil Général s'emploie offrir au
public des espaces naturels en
adéquation avec les attentes et
l'évolution de la société les 350 r
d'accueil aménagé très prisés du public
favorise une pratique répandue au sein
de la population qui est devenu une
véritable institution le pique-nique à
l'image de Python sec ces sites sont
devenus des lieux incontournables d'une
forme d'immersion dans un environnement
naturel et la route du volcan sera
bientôt aménagée en route
d'interprétation avec des points de vue
et des nouvelles aires de pique-nique
qui seront réalisés dès cette année et
jusqu'en 2016
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais